president Trump announcing the location
of his first mag a rally later this
month we're gonna start our rallies back
up now the first one we believe will be
probably we're just starting to call up
we'll be in Oklahoma in Tulsa Oklahoma
and we're going to be coming into
Florida do a big one in Florida a big
one in Texas they're all going to be big
we're going to Arizona we're going to
North Carolina at the appropriate time
meanwhile Democrats are happy to keep
Joe Biden in his basement one of his top
surrogates Terry McAuliffe admitting
he's fine with keeping the former VP
there alright one I'd like to start with
you I'd actually like to get your
thoughts on the notion that outside of
DC Atlanta mayor Keisha Lance bottoms is
looking like the increasingly pick for
the VP over Camilla Harris what are your
thoughts on that the only place I've
seen that is in a pretty conservative
newspaper and I've not heard that from
anybody involved with any campaign not I
mean I pro or con
she's a wonderful mayor and she had a
wonderful statement in terms of
protecting Atlanta during the trouble
last week so I think her national
profile has come up but I have not heard
that she is suddenly in the lead for VP
you know but in general Emily I think
that as we consider what we just heard
from Terry McAuliffe I just want to
salute him as being an honest man I just
think he told the truth Joe Biden's a
good retail politician but this election
is shaping up as a referendum on Donald
Trump and so far the polls indicate
Donald Trump is losing to Donald Trump
so to my mind what you got is a
situation where yeah if he if Joe Biden
is like standing there as an alternative
most Americans are clearly saying we
prefer the alternative one last point on
that VP thing even if Joe Biden doesn't
pick a black woman and given all the
racial trouble at the moment you think
oh well that's a logical choice it would
stir up the base you know the number one
pick among black voters for VP Elizabeth
Warren mmm Jesse what are your thoughts
on that the one reference so you know
what hope does the Democratic Party have
they're in a civil war
and they don't care if their figurehead
is in the basement yeah they've been
hiding Biden in the basement and they
looked at a rigged CNN poll and think
they're doing okay I'll be perfectly
honest you know you had a quarter where
you had the Chinese virus which was very
deadly you had racial riots you had a
snap recession so it's been a
challenging second quarter for this
Republican president in an election year
especially when 95% of the media is
negative with that set the more things
return to normal which they will the
worse it is for Joe Biden eventually
he's going to have to come out of his
basement he's going to have to give his
little tiny speeches it's very very
small events he's going to have to give
interviews without looking at his notes
he's going to have to start answering
questions from a gaggle of media
reporters and we all know he's not the
most talented guy he was kind of the
default pick in the primary everybody
else just kind of lost so they said okay
we'll go with Joe not a good fundraiser
not a good debater not that great of a
campaigner and president Trump has been
fighting to a button with one hand tied
behind his back once this stops and he
can go out and hold a rally things
change these rallies are kind of like
the lifeblood for the president they get
the base energized they can pull out all
the data from all these people they're
you know you buy 50,000 Magga masks you
strap them on you do two hours of the
deep red state things will get back to
normal and do I look worried not yet
Lawrence the Biden campaign today said
that they hear calls from the black
community to instill a black female vice
president and also from the Latino
community to choose a Latina what are
your thoughts on that and especially how
the campaign is navigating this national
conversation well but button has a huge
problem and all of the the things that
he's banking on has nothing to do with
him as a candidate he's dependent on
others so number one he's expecting
Barack Obama to be the guy that go out
there and bring people together and I
was just note that didn't work out too
well for Hillary Clinton the second
thing that he's banking on is his VP
still not him
depending on someone that is a black
woman or a minority and I think he's
going to choose a black woman to bring
the country together to close that gap
between those progressive voters to make
sure that black people are definitely
gonna turn out he's dependent on that
and the third thing he's depending on is
that there that there would be tension
still in the country when it comes to
race relations that America would still
want someone to have peace in the
country and it's still an anti-trump
message none of the things that he's
banking on says that I'm a good
candidate that's why he's in the
basement hmm Dana what are your thoughts
well I have 30 seconds left so I I would
just say that if you listen to the full
audio of Terry McAuliffe he's I think
some people are suggesting that they're
like please stay in the basement you're
so gas prone but that's not what Terry
McAuliffe was saying if you listened to
it he was saying that Joe Biden just
needs to be strategic where he can be
and he'll be fine and things will evolve
I agree with Jessi as soon as those
rallies get started you'll see that
enthusiasm pick up but there is there's
no doubt it's it's been a challenging
quarter and if you see a Gallup drop
like that month to month it gets harder
to try to win every single week between
now and November but of course
everybody's gonna give it a try